So the Roadblock problem is know to be exponential-time complete,
which means it's provably harder than any problem in NP
even on a nondeterministic machine.
And the proof does not depend on whether P=NP or not.
The proof is certain; Roadblock is harder than any problem in NP.
So it's harder than, say, vertex cover.
Now why is that? Why can't nondeterminism help us to solve Roadblock?
Well, it can help us, but it apparently can't help us enough
to make this problem solvable in NP.
So there's several ways to explain this, and 1 of the differences
between NP and problems that are harder than NP is that in NP,
or, more concretely, in a problem like vertex cover, you're dealing with a static input.
You're given 1 graph, and for that graph you're trying to solve 1 question.
And that question is: Do you have a vertex cover of a certain size?
Asking for an optimal strategy in a game like Roadblock is a bit different
because this game is played against a player.
So the question kind of is: After player 1 has made a move, what can player 2 do?
And player 2, of course, has a number of possible reactions to what player 1 has done.
You need to take all of these possibilities into consideration.
How player 1 makes the second move or the third move
always depends on what player 2 is doing in between.
And that is why this problem here is intuitively exponential-time complete,
because after every move that player 1 makes,
you have to consider all of the possibilities that player 2 makes.
And there's no way around that, instead of here,
where we can just guess a small vertex cover.
There's a description for this that is a little bit more formal.
You can say that NP is kind of the set of problems that have a short proof.
And by short, I mean a polynomial-time verifiable proof.
So, for example, for vertex cover, when I tell you
I have a vertex cover that only uses 5 vertices,
and you ask me, please show me that vertex cover,
well, I can just specify those 5 vertices to you,
and you can check yourself that they will make up a vertex cover for the input graph.
Now, for a game like Roadblock, that is not that easy,
because if you said, "Player 1 can always win this game,"
and I asked you--I wanted proof of that, then we again get into
this situation that the proof of the optimal strategy is exponential in size.
Because that proof will basically start out by saying,
okay, this is the first move that player 1 should make,
but then there are a couple of reactions that player 2 could have to that move.
So, let's say it branches out; so this is what player 1 is doing,
and this is what player 2 is doing.
Now, for each of these reactions of player 2, I will again in this proof
have to specify what player 1 is supposed to do.
But then, as you see, it branches out. Player 2 again has a number
of possible reactions that it can have to this move.
For Roadblock, if you think of this as a large search tree,
it doesn't suffice to show that there's just 1 single path that leads to a solution,
but basically  you have to show that any path here in this tree
always leads to player 1 winning.
So for vertex cover or any other problem in NP
and, of course, this is again talking very informally,
it suffices to show 1 path in the search tree.
Whereas for a problem like Roadblock, the proof that, for example,
player 1 can always win, would require you to show the whole search tree
and not just a single path, and that is why problems such as Roadblock
are provably harder than problems in NP.